all right welcome everybody back on
twitch a lot of stuff to talk about
today did a stream or two streams last
week I guess it was one on YouTube one
on Twitch last week streaming tonight
probably streaming a little bit earlier
tomorrow have to see what my schedule is
like but a whole bunch of stuff to talk
about including I see a lot of people in
the chat already talking about next
week's presidential primary debate and
I'm going to talk about that in a little
bit and will I be streaming where will I
be streaming very exciting thing
happening today which is that I am
starting to have subscribers on Twitch
who have subscribed for their second
month in a row I've only been on Twitch
for like five weeks this is my second
that started my second month and I want
to say thanks to Matt jc3 who subscribed
for two months at Tier one want to say
thanks to Gilmore goth who has
subscribed for two months with prime and
thanks to the carfax for cheering 300
bits so let's just even do this before
we go any further hundreds and hundreds
of people who signed up with twitch
Prime in August it's September now and
your twitch prime subs have expired you
can immediately Reese absque Ribe to my
channel with twitch prime please do so
if you have an Amazon Prime account you
can do it cost you nothing paid
subscription for us please do that right
now and I will thank you I will thank
everybody who signs up with twitch prime
during the livestream and hopefully
there will be many of you I am going to
be I've got a couple videos I want to
play for you which I haven't yet watched
but have been sent to me I want to go
over I will probably take the moral
foundations test people last time asking
me to take that and I'm ready to do it
it's only 36 questions I've read a lot
about it and I've read Jonathan heights
work so I sort of know a few different
things about it
and I'm going to take it and we'll see
how all of that goes thanks to V do taht
for subscribing with twitch prime thanks
to maestro panda for subscribing at
tier-one appreciate that muffin boy and
Ginobili have subscribed with
prime which I of course very very much
appreciate did not see anything lfn
about Warren about to flip-flop on
medicare-for-all but maybe we will we
will get to that okay
it is September yes exactly right davon
ciske says the artwork behind me that is
just a poster I got in Paris that's it I
think it's you know a poster of some
kind of well-known piece of art I'm not
really sure
rust call asking what I consider making
t-shirts for fans with a logo on the
front and the back would read you got
DP'd I don't know probably not it is
annoying Erin that twitch makes Yuri
subscribe every month with twitch prime
but the whole goal is regular twitch
subscriptions Auto renew and prime subs
don't the idea being maybe after your
first month you would then come back and
subscribe not with twitch prime so that
Amazon can actually make money that's my
guess about it but I'm not totally sure
okay we are very very shortly going to
be getting to a bunch of different
videos that I have but before we do that
I will mention that as is often the case
if folks are interested in me taking
live phone calls sometimes people don't
even know what it means for me to open
up the phones I will open up the phone
line six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty if we get fifteen new
members on my website okay why on my
website what about all of these other
things I can't say in detail what
portion of your money all of these
different platforms take but everybody
takes money whether it's twitch patreon
YouTube all of this different stuff on
my website we pay a two point nine
percent fee and then otherwise we get
all the money that's more than we get
anywhere else so that's why we focus on
website subscriptions they're our
primary source of funding
if fifteen people sign up I will thank
each and every one of you and then I
will open up the phone lines and
hopefully I will be hearing from you
before we know it let's see here before
jump into some of this stuff Amazon
wants twitch users to get Amazon Prime
that's the goal oh that's a debt that's
fair as well the country boy 420
subscribing with twitch Prime for the
second month in a row very much
appreciate that Kelley Wiegand and the
CARFAX also subscribing for one month at
tier one very very much appreciate that
okay so let's just do a straw poll for
the first thing that I'm gonna do I will
either okay so I have two things here
let me type them out there's a Lauren
Chen video and then debate plan for next
week okay let me create this poll oh I
did it wrong which first which first
debate plan for next week Lauren Chen
video create poll okay I'm gonna paste
the straw poll right into the chat and
then people can vote I'll paste it a
couple of times there okay let's see
what people want
alright I will either talk about the
debate plan for next week first in terms
of streaming and if there's a whole
backstory related to it or we will look
at the Lauren Chen video and depends
what I'm gonna do both it's just a
question of what people want me to do
first
we'll give it a few moments there there
was some other question here what's my
words per minute David I type about like
100 to 115 I think if you don't know who
Lauren Chen is that's fine that's part
of the goof talk with Hassan o Hassan is
back yeah yeah yeah maybe later I will
see if Hassan wants to chat
are people laughing cuz a hundred words
per minute is high or low I don't even
know I've been typing paper since I was
8 years old so I don't know I can type
some people don't want Lauren Chan okay
all right I'm gonna give it like 30 more
seconds the straw poll I'll link the
straw poll one more time Mike enough
I've been told I'm not allowed to say
how much I get for each twitch prime sub
so I won't alright about 30 seconds left
looks like there is a clear winner here
Oh ID by the way people let me make
another note I am actually set up to
play Super Mario World people asked last
time about that there was a whole thing
that came up related to that maybe I'll
do that I don't know okay we're gonna
talk about the debate plan for next week
first so here's the deal we're going to
talk about the debates momentarily so as
many of you know I arrived I made an
account on Twitch months and months ago
and I just was like unsure when do I
start things are going pretty well on
YouTube YouTube prime subscriptions
thanks anslee for the subscription and I
had this twitch account ready to go
didn't know what to do with it and then
in what was it late I guess it was the
last few days of July
it was the second democratic debate
which was this one yeah July 31st 30th
to 31st started live streaming on
YouTube we were two minutes into the
debate I already had like 12,000 live
concurrent viewers or something like
that we were on target for like 40,000
live viewers and then a CNN shut me down
and then their VP of corporate
communications or something started
tweeting how I was just a horrible
person and doing all sorts of terrible
things so I literally took 30 minutes
and and went over and streamed on Twitch
and we had like 6,000 or so live viewers
and a whole bunch of people signed up
for twitch Prime subs and all this stuff
and all of a sudden I'm on Twitch
the second night which as you can see
here was July 31st did the same thing
and we had a nice audience and all of a
sudden I'm on Twitch and I've been
Street streaming regularly so then the
question came up and it's been coming up
a lot recently there's another debate
what is the date September 12 2019
is the first time that the Democratic
field is down to only one night because
we're down to only ten polls and we're
gonna talk about that momentarily show
that and show this we're gonna talk
about all of this stuff are you going to
be streaming at all are you going to
stream on YouTube or are you going to
stream on Twitch or are you going to try
using restream to stream on both so I
mean there's like a million things going
on here to talk about first of all
officially I've been told twitch doesnt
allow affiliates which I am to stream to
the at the same time to youtube and
twitch I've also been told it's not
really enforced if you're an affiliate
that if you're a partner it's enforced
so the possibility of screaming - both
at the same time is on the table I have
set up restream but I have not tested it
so if someone wants to help me figure
out if there's some offline way to test
it without publishing an actual event
I'm hoping to may be looking at doing
both but I am NOT going to stream live
commentary of next week's debate on
YouTube unless what where's this the
debate I believe this is an ABC
Univision debate
unless ABC Univision tell my YouTube rep
that I am clear to stream if I if I
don't get whitelisted so to speak I'm
not gonna do it it's just too risky
in that case I will certainly wink wink
consider doing it on Twitch although
it's not any more legal or illegal it's
just maybe I can get away with it I
don't know so I'll have information
about that I emailed my youtube rep
today about this and if she doesn't have
some kind of yes for me by like next
Tuesday or something like that I'll
probably make the call that we're gonna
be doing the live stream of the debate
on Twitch and I will announce it and it
will be you know just a huge party and
you know we'll do all the stuff that
that we previously did
so did I ask beforehand last time no but
by the way a lot of people saying do I
want to be a partner on Twitch I don't
know that I do because as a partner on
Twitter not allowed to stream anywhere
else and as you can see here I have
seven hundred and twenty three thousand
subscribers on YouTube and it is
climbing every day by five hundred to a
thousand so that's still a big platform
I want to be able to stream on Twitch
but I also
to be able to stream on YouTube and I I
just I I don't know that I want to be a
twitch partner for that reason YouTube
is still gonna be a big part of what I'm
doing so as far as the specifics of the
debate oh let me thank some more people
here
Jinja subscribed for the second month at
tier one with the message the legend
thank you I appreciate that
Jim Bowen the Barbarian has given out
five community sub gifts
thanks so much Jimbo and I appreciate
that Moondog 22 has subscribed for two
months with twitch Prime and wavedash
has subscribed for the first month at
Tier one yes please remember if you
subscribed with twitch Prime last year
now people are misunderstanding me I
know I can stream on Twitch without
being a partner I'm doing it right now
twitch doesnt allow partners to stream
elsewhere am i being this unclear I feel
like I'm being clear if you subscribe
last month with twitch prime it has
expired
please check if you can subscribe again
because hundreds and hundreds of your
memberships have have expired so you've
got to do it again alright now I am
going to talk about who is in the third
debate but before I do that let me say
thanks to Matt P who signed up on my
website for a new membership and say
thanks to Edward ker that gets us to 2
out of 15 well that's the wrong line 2
out of 15 new members as you can see up
there info is their counter is their if
we get to 15 I will open up the phones
and let people call in so please do that
ok the third debate is going to be an
interesting one it's gonna be
interesting in a few ways number one
this is the first debate that is going
to be on only one night because we are
down to 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 candidates
all right the requirements were by
October 28th a candidate needed a
hundred and thirty thousand unique
donors at least four hundred unique
donors per day state in 20 states and a
candidate needed to get at least two
percent support in four different polls
from an approved list which is the
source of some controversy now some
people
it should still be two nights but five
people per night because then you can go
in more depth I want more depth I don't
disagree with you at the same time we've
had two debates where you are not seeing
all of the candidates interacting with
each other I want to see Warren and
Biden and Sanders on the same stage and
for that reason I think it's good that
we're finally down to one night
although 10 people is still way too many
so as you can see we've got Biden Warren
Sanders Harris Buddha judge yang Booker
O'Rourke and Klobuchar and who Leon
Castro now of these people at this point
I believe that there are only three who
really have a shot at this nomination
that's Biden Warren and Sanders Kamala
Harris is polling 7% something I mean
just mind-blowing would have to happen
at the third debate for her to have a
shot Bhutto judges polling four point
six percent and I just don't see any way
that he is going to do anything
Andrew yang is a very interesting and as
you know I've interviewed him many times
on my program i I don't think the math
is there for him but I want to see how
far he can get because he's an
interesting candidate and who else
Booker and O'Rourke there at two and a
half percent I don't think they've got
much of a shot Amy Klobuchar is done and
who Leon Castro is also done now then it
gets interesting because you have these
three other candidates Tom Steyer who's
just a rich dude tulsi gabbard
and marianne williamson Tom Steyer
entered the race pretty recently and
just basically paid his way in and if
you're a rich guy you can get donors and
it's it's really a weird thing that he's
even running but you're not gonna see
much of him because again he's not even
on the debate stage tulsi gabbard a lot
of people are angry saying that the DNC
screwed her because they picked polls
that she didn't get two percent in the
list of the polls that were considered
qualifying has been around for a very
long time so I just don't see that as a
very good argument and then Marianne
Williamson was just kind of a fluke
whose personality interestingly enough
got her quite a bit of attention and she
actually did well in the last debate I
am getting I see people in the chat I am
getting just endless furious furious
furious emails
from Telsey supporters saying I'm not
giving her enough attention when I talk
about her I'm saying the wrong things
etc etc I mean listen Tulsi never had a
shot and she still doesn't have a shot
what do you want me to say am I supposed
to be apologizing for that my a bad
person
every time I've mentioned Tulsi I
there's a contingent of my audience that
is just furious give me a break guys
come on
let me say thanks to a couple other
people XT PHT why is that XT fitty to
subscribe to twitch prime thank you
bride clutches subscribed for two months
at Tier one thanks for the second month
subscription Fineman taco has subscribed
for one month and Jim boned the
Barbarian subscribed for two months with
prime thank you got a haircut recently
appreciate that people like it oh are we
going to I say are we going to have a
bit war tonight yeah so last last stream
there was a massive bit war RJC and
turkey bacon and cheese we're going back
and forth back and forth
as it stands rj c is the number one
all-time top cheer with 25,000 bits
turkey bacon and cheese is in second
place with twenty thousand and one I
think it would be nice just to see
someone else break the top five because
it's it's actually you you only need to
get to one thousand five hundred and six
bits to get into the top five that's
pretty low the issue is between second
and third place it's like 18,000 bits
that separate them so I don't know if
we're gonna have a twitch war tonight
but a bit war tonight but why not I
would love it Gary the sea cow has
subscribed with twitch prime Xenocide
has subscribed for the second month in a
row at Tier one and Roemer underscore
has subscribed with twitch prime I
appreciate that thank you
oh is uh is destiny also streaming right
now I should see who that I follow is
streaming right now because maybe we
could do some interesting stuff we rated
trihex
last time this nonsense so destiny is
streaming Hassan is streaming the serfs
are streaming and that's it from the
people that I follow right now all right
so we'll see about that soon
okay so anyway demo the long and short
of it is I'll let you know soon whether
I'm in a stream next week's debate on
YouTube on Twitch both neither or
whatever okay let's no talk about this
video so I have not watched this yet
people sent this to me I met this is
Lauren Chen she's known as the roving
millennial or the roaming millennial
rather I guess she now works for the
blaze which is a right-wing outlet and
she is a right-winger again it's born in
Canada raised in Hong Kong okay whatever
so anyway when I was at politican last
year I did I was on a panel with her she
was perfectly nice to me as a person and
you know I don't agree with anything she
says I people sent this video to me
saying oh here's the blaze logo yeah so
she is part of the place saying she did
a thing about how there's just more gay
people than ever and we're getting gayer
and gayer and blah blah blah let's take
a look at what she had to say because
this is actually something that that
I've studied and talked about on the
program before oh but before I do this
let me also say thanks to max Shadegg
max Shadegg or shad egg is my third new
website member of the evening we're at 3
out of 15 I'm glad to open the phone
lines and take phone calls info is right
there join pakman.com 3 out of 15 I'll
thank everybody info is over there all
right let's just get into this and see
what she has to say
NBC author proudly proclaimed that
heterosexuality apparently just wasn't
working because screw men I guess if you
haven't seen that video yet I recommend
you check it out but today we are gonna
continue our discussion of human
sexuality and what influences it
specifically did you know that as a
society we are getting gayer yup as NBC
News reports quote a record
four-and-a-half percent of American
adults identify
gay bisexual or transgender according to
a new Gallup estimate the percentage
which works out to more than 11 million
US adults is up from 4% in 2016 and 3.5%
in 2012 the Year Gallup first started
tracking LGBT identification obviously
this discussion about human sexuality
okay before going even further so okay I
mean I'm gonna give this let's let's
listen to it a little bit more quickly
because I don't think I can tolerate it
at normal speed this has been studied
extensively and there's a difference
between identifying in a pole as LGBT
and being LGBT why might it be that the
younger you are the more likely you are
to identify as LGBT huh well the younger
you are the more likely you are also to
be accepting of people who are LGBT to
not see LGBT people as sinners
bla bla bla bla bla so it's simply more
accepted and less stigmatized to say
that you IRI LGBT in 2019 than in
previous years there's not actually any
evidence so far I mean Gallup surveys
people's opinions about stuff and
people's ideology so far there's no
evidence that there are actually more
gay people but lycée people are saying
that we've already seen enough and this
is so obvious let's just see if she
addresses it maybe she says hold on a
second maybe more people say that they
are LGBT today because they are more
comfortable saying it rather than
because there are actually more gay
people it's made a little more
complicated by the fact that trans
identities are always included in these
polls even though gender identity is
really not the same thing as sexual
orientation like at all but in any case
this is the best we got a 1% increase
over five years of people identifying as
LGBT three point five percent in 2012 to
four point five percent in 2017 may not
sound so it's not a one percent increase
its a one percentage point increase this
is I mean so this is what for this is
what we're fighting against this is
man like a huge jump but the difference
is even more pronounced when we look at
the generational breakdown the increase
was driven primarily by Millennials
defined as those born between 1980 and
1999 according to the reports findings
in 2012 5.8 percent of this cohort
answered yes when asked do you
personally identify as lesbian gay
bisexual or transgender in the 2017
estimate that number jumped 40 percent
to 8.2 percent of Millennials in
contrast Gallup found the LGBT
identification rate of older generations
is steady in the latest survey three
point five percent of Generation X
respondents identified as lesbian gay
bisexual or transgender two point four
percent of baby boomers and one point
four percent of traditionalists clearly
Millennials are a lot more likely than
older generations to identify as being
LGBT that is not true well to identify
yeah they're more likely to be
comfortable saying it right I mean this
is a the are we she's talking about we
are getting gayer versus we are more
likely to say this this is just I mean
this is this what the right seizes
thought leadership and activists will
usually say that this increase in
statistics is simply due to our society
now being more often tolerant of LGBTI
dimension it used to be ie it's not
really that more people are LGBT than
before it's just that more people are
comfortable admitting that they're LGBTQ
I believe the NBC article supports this
viewpoint by saying quote Gary gates and
LD be demographics experts said it's not
surprising that a great proportion of
Millennials are comfortable being more
open about their LGBT status social
acceptance of the LGBT population has
increased substantially over the last
decade and those changes have been more
pronounced in younger populations gates
told NBC News via email today's youth
have peers and social networks that are
more supportive of LGBT people and
issues when compared to older
generations and the article goes on to
explain that quote Millennials have been
found to be significantly more accepting
of lesbian gay bisexual and transgender
rights turns away according to a 2017
NBC news/wall Street Journal poll
seventy five percent of people aged 18
to 34 support same-sex unions compared
to just 42% of people over 65 so if all
of these polls aren't really indicative
of how many LGBT people there really are
simply how many LGBT people feel
comfortable admitting well that's
literally what the poll is the pole is
not checking in any kind of empirically
verifiable way whether
someone is what they say they are the
poll is just what are people saying she
says she's like let me go back that
that's the weirdest wait how did she
phrase that simply how many LGBT people
feel comfortable admitting their LGBT
yeah it's a poll of how many people say
they are LGBT it's not a poll of the
number of gay people in society then it
does beg the question how many that's
not what beg the question means that
that's not what beg the question means
is she really she's using beg the
question wrong the LGBT people are there
actually well for decades some LGBT
activists have been saying that as many
as 1 in 10 or 10 percent of people are
lesbian gay bisexual or transgender and
although on the surface that number may
seem really high considering that now
over 8 percent of Millennials already
identify as LGBT perhaps that statistic
isn't as crazy as it seems like I
mentioned Guam the official explanation
for this is that we're just becoming
more accepting of how we've always been
surely I can't be the only one who finds
it interesting that the number of woke
celebrities who come out as either queer
non-binary or otherwise special
I mean LGBT seems to be increasing
literally by the day like we talked
about in my other video Miley Cyrus and
Julian Hoff what does that have to do
with anything our two celebrities who
recently in interviews with progressive
women's magazines came out as not being
attracted exclusively to men and Bella
Thorne one of those X Disney child stars
turned decidedly not family-friendly
also recently came out as bisexual and
then even more recently than that hand
sexual in the past she's used Twitter to
casually come out as bisexual but today
she's expanded her sexual orientation
I'm actually a pansexual okay somebody
somebody explained to me what that is
explain that to me you like beings you
like what you like doesn't have to be a
girl or a guy or you know he is she a
day or this or that it's literally you
like personality like you just like a
being look I wish bella thorne
all the best with her newfound
pansexuality and historically it is true
that gay people have always existed I'm
not trying to say that gayness is
something the SJW is just invented to
seem trendy because oh that's good that
you're not saying that because that
would be crazy obviously that's not the
case however I do have to say that the
degree to which our culture now
Jews heteronormativity and
heterosexuality isn't something we've
seen since maybe the ancient Greeks
believed that the most master that that
I mean now it's just a straw man nobody
nobody is a shooing heterosexuality this
this is just so stupid oh my goodness I
think are we done with this insta it
chat pull of chat poll or have we
basically seen enough to know everything
we need to know about this yeah okay
people seem to be in it nobody seems to
want to continuous no more yeah okay I
think I've seen enough of this stuff Wow
okay let me before I move on to the next
thing I'll say thanks to a few other
people stunt man stan has subscribed
June Dawes is a new twitch sub sig watch
has subscribed and electrician
apprentice has subscribed agent b64 has
subscribed for two months with prime MTB
5 to 294 has subscribed for two months
with prime desert rat 4 has subscribed
and Sonia
Ahmed has subscribed with prime and I
really appreciate all of you remember I
mentioned at the top of the show that a
lot of people's twitch prime subs have
expired since the last stream so even if
you remember having signed up with
twitch prime do it again if you're able
to because those don't automatically
renew if you've never subscribed with
twitch prime really please also do it if
you have Amazon Prime you can subscribe
with twitch prime it costs you nothing
but it supports the work that I do and
violet Eve is the newest such twitch
prime subscriber ok I see a lot of
question Oh pink people so I mentioned
that I would open the phones if we get
15 website members and the number is six
one seven eight three zero 47 50 but the
phone lines are not yet open we need 12
more people to sign up on my website
join pakman.com and I do encourage you
to do that you get extra content every
day you support the work that I do
directly you fund all of our ongoing
operations it's the most solid and
reliable source of funding because the
subscriptions don't expire automatically
every month like something on Twitch but
the phone line is not open
right now but a whole bunch of people
are calling in let's just as a goof
take a listen from Oh Jimmy from Philly
the angry drunk Trump estelle din okay
listen I'll play I'll play a voicemail
from Jimmy from Philly he's out of
control
if people like this then please sign up
on my website afterwards because these
are the types of calls I sometimes get
let's take a listen David Jimmy Quinn
Chloe start beer
shreds Trump says I'm homosexual house
on truck on Trump we should take this
more on this Danny bastard seriously no
you [ __ ] kidding me
no extremely insightful and precise
political analysis as you can see and
those may be the types of calls that
come in if we indeed do open up the
phone line so please please please it
takes under a minute go over to my
website join pakman.com maybe I'll even
demo how to sign up momentarily okay let
me say thanks to a couple people and
then I'm going to take the moral
foundations test if people have videos
that they want me to review like the
Lauren Chen video I'm glad to check out
a couple but you'll have to let me know
what they are okay Rhyno double zeros
welcome for your second month in a row I
appreciate that
Asha aleena 77 has subscribed with
twitch prime Aaron Nance has subscribed
for the second month in a row with
twitch prime message loved the show
propably no has subscribed with twitch
prime metal one dragon has subscribed
with twitch prime I appreciate that what
do I think about sam Harris his recent
segment on white supremacy versus
jihadism breaking news Sam Harris is
gonna be on my show in the next week
I have not announced that anywhere yet
but Sam Harris is scheduled unless
something changes to be on my show in
the next seven days and we will have him
for the hour as Larry King used to say
so that is going to prove to be very
very interesting if that is titillating
to you
head on over and become a member on my
website memberships directly support the
long form interviews okay all right let
me jump into the moral foundations test
so I'll give you a little background on
this you can take this at IDR labs.com
this is called the moral foundations
test I've never taken this test but I've
read quite a bit about it in his book
the righteous mind
Jonathan Hite writes about how early in
his psychology career as an academic
psychologist he started developing a
test where he would ask people questions
that were geared to get a specific sort
of visceral reaction and he would have
different scenarios but they were
specifically worded where the principles
at play and many of the questions were
the same but they would be worded in
such a way that people would react to
them differently if that makes sense and
a version of that test is now available
online it's the moral foundations test
and all you have to do is basically say
whether these different scenarios are or
are not moral and then I believe that
the answers the the results will
basically tell you where you place on a
multivariate sort of moral matrix so I'm
going to take this test I invite you to
take it with me you go to IDR labs.com
I'll just give people a second to do it
yeah Det I'm not gonna spend 90 percent
of the time with Sam Harris bashing the
left but what I do want to talk to him
about is he and I have been critics over
the left from the left but I think that
we don't agree as to what the major
problems with the left are so I think
that that will be an interesting piece
of the conversation and I look forward
to talking with him about that
thank you - lightning ran who subscribed
for two months in a row with twitch
prime love your show on this format
thank you glad to be here and nurse
Jilly who subscribed for the first time
with twitch Prime I appreciate that as
well alright let's just jump right into
this moral foundations test okay anybody
I'm guessing who's going to take it with
is probably found it already an army
lieutenant neglects to file a report on
a civilian killing done by his troops
because he knows it was an accident I'm
gonna try to just think about each of
these individually not anticipating what
I know are some of the other types of
questions I think it is just absolutely
not okay there needs to be full
accountability and investigation of all
killings that take place in the military
so I think that's totally not okay Tina
promises her dying mother that she'll
visit her grave once a month after the
mother has passed away Tina finds it
hard to squeeze in the time and visits
drop to about once a year I think that
that's completely fine I mean I don't
believe that the mother is looking down
in some way and and and I don't believe
that there is any negative impact if
Tina has things going on in her life
such that she can't do that
I don't see any problem with it Amy and
Mia are coworkers one day Amy offers Mia
to take one of her shifts no strings
attached sometime later Amy could really
use someone to fill in for her but Mia
doesn't feel compelled because Amy's
offer had no strings attached I think it
is okay but there is a sort of social
convention here that would dictate that
you should probably do it but if it
really is no strings attached
call it no strings attached and operate
on that basis in biology class a human
hand preserved in a jar is passed around
among the students don't see any problem
with that
Adam and Beth have been dating for three
years Adam is reluctant to have children
so Beth tells him that she's on the pill
when he isn't I think that that is
terrible when she isn't I think that one
of the worst things you can do is bring
a child in to the world that the parents
didn't want to have and I think that
that's extremely problematic a group of
parents cancer I'll stop every six
questions and see what's happening with
the chat group of parents concerned
about their children's risk of obesity
demand that the local store stop selling
extra-large size candy bars and soft
drinks I have no problem with the demand
that being said you know the
I was raised it didn't matter what size
candy bars were available or what soft
drinks were available I didn't drink
soda barely ever and I didn't get excel
candy bars at all if I mean every once
in a while whatever so I think that it's
if the question is is it okay for the
parents to demand it it's okay is that
the solution and does the store have to
do it the answer is no okay let's see
what else is going on here let me say
thanks to Aerith a kosaka Hodge who
subscribed for one month at Tier one I
really appreciate that oh dear no new
website members that's not good
we got three real quick 3 out of 15 but
now we've been sitting at three for a
while I will open the phone lines and
take your phone calls if we get to 15
website members it takes a minute folks
it really it does and it's really cheap
if you use that coupon code over there
you're talking about like three dollars
a month very cheap I encourage you to do
it uh okay let's continue let's do six
more of these questions a man orders a
custom-built
sex doll designed to look just like his
niece okay so this is this is these are
designed specifically so it's just a sex
doll so what difference does it make
better a sex doll than his actual niece
for sure I don't see anything wrong with
the order but it's certainly indicative
of someone who is having problematic
feelings towards their niece now from
the way the questions asked it's not
even clear whether the niece is underage
or not obviously I think that that would
be an aggravating factor but I think
that I guess I'll just leave it in the
middle it's like I don't ordering the
doll is not a problem in and of itself
the fact that he wants one that looks
like his niece is a problem it's
disturbing behavior but I think I'd
leave it in the middle when on a live
on-air TV show a TV show a man kills a
baby rabbit with a knife unless this is
a show about hunting and preparing your
own food I would say it is not okay
that this is a sort of a poorly worded
worded question because I don't have any
problem with hunting for food you're
going to eat but just killing rabbits in
a sort of sadistic way is a problem
without any context it's sort of hard to
know so I guess any question that seems
problematic and how it's phrased I'll
just leave in the middle
Sara's dog has four puppies she can only
find a home for two of them so she kills
the other two with a stone to the head I
don't think this is okay now I know a
lot of people will say well if you bring
them to a shelter they'll just kill them
and you know euthanize them at the
shelter I still think that that would be
better they can do it in a way where you
know a stone to the head it's not clear
that the puppy is not suffering and also
at this point in time I can't think of
any reason why you wouldn't be able to
do something other than that and there
are many no-kill shelters around so I
would say no Jane's boss calls all of
his employees by their Jane's boss calls
all of his employees by their first
names but does not allow any of them to
call him by his first name when Jane
insists that it must be a two-way street
he fires her so it seems not okay in
that it doesn't seem like a good reason
to fire someone it is not for Jane to
decide presumably how people should be
addressed it doesn't appear to be
illegal and it's not how I would run
things so I think that it is not okay
but you know unfortunately it doesn't
it's based on labor law in much of this
country that that's it is what it is
Julie asked her friends not to
fraternize with her ex-boyfriend Jake
since he cheated on her with other women
three weeks later Julie's friend Melissa
is dating him well so it's what okay
like is this this question isn't even
clear whether the problem is Julie's ask
or Melissa doing the dating I don't
really see any problem with Melissa
doing the dating she's going against
what her friend asked and that may be a
problem for Julie but I mean it's this
is just like does anybody even
understand what I'm
the answering with this one is weird
Julie's friend melissa is dating him is
the dating okay or not okay I don't
really think it's a problem I have to
say but it's so poorly worded I'll leave
it in the middle Hannah
inherited an old flag of her country
from her father but has never used it
one day when Hannah is cleaning the
house she discovers that she is out of
rag so she uses the flag as a rag to
clean the house I don't really have any
hang-ups about flags so I just think
that's okay I mean I have a hard time
feeling too strongly about what other
people do with flags
if the flag means something to you then
you treat the flag in a certain way if
it doesn't to someone else I mean it's
just fabric all right let me catch up
with what's happening in the chat here
momentum space has subscribed with
twitch Prime I appreciate that
what about burning a flag asks Connor
Poe burning flags as conch the
constitutionally protected speech in the
United States and and that's that's just
it I don't I don't know what else to
tell you it's asking if I'm okay with
the dating let's go back three weeks
later Julie's friend Melissa is dating
him you know I'm pretty neutral about
the dating it's really just an issue
between Melissa and Julie and whether
she thinks Jake is gonna be doing the
cheating so I stand by that okay all
right let me continue here Rhapsody's
Rhapsody's on grows i'm not sure how to
pronounce that has subscribed for two
months in a row with twitch prime I
appreciate that thank you okay Emma and
Cindy are summer interns at Chris's
office am i just slightly better than
Cindy at the end of the summer there's
only one opening but Chris gives it to
Cindy because he finds her more
attractive I think it's not okay for
it's it's not good for the business and
I don't think it's good morally it's not
illegal
I might have slightly better than Cindy
so in principle if what we're evaluating
is people's work then Emma should get
the job so I think it's not okay
slightly but this is not you know the
end of the world Bob and Pam are
siblings bob has given $10 by their
father and is told that
distribute it between them as he likes
Bob gives $1 to Pam and pockets the nine
himself I think it's okay but not great
Bob was told distributed the way you
want
and certainly distributing in this way
could have consequences and then in the
future Bob and Pam's dad would make
different decisions some men have a
private all-male Club and feminists take
them to court demanding that they open
it up to women I have very mixed
feelings about this stuff I don't really
have a problem with private clubs that
are geared towards certain groups at the
same time this is how a lot of
discrimination ends up sort of festering
and self-perpetuating
so let me read it again some men have a
private all-male Club and feminists take
them to court demanding that they open
it up to women I mean it's okay that the
feminists take them to court there's a
question as to whether there should be
such a legal thing as a private all-male
Club you know I have a problem with like
a male-only golf course the way that the
one in Atlanta is but is it okay for
there to be a club for men I mean it's
like I have friends who are in men's
groups where they just talk about men's
issues and it's for men what would
happen if a woman tried to attend
I'm guessing she'd be told it's just for
men sort of difficult the way it's
worded I'm just gonna leave it in the
middle a new action figure becomes all
the rage among the boys in Timmy's class
when Timmy's parents get to the store
they buy all of the action figures for
Timmy leaving none for the children I
think that this is not okay in the sense
that I mean listen they're not doing
anything legally wrong but Timmy's not
learning any particular lesson that is
useful in life as a result of this other
than lessons maybe we don't want kids to
learn there's diminishing marginal
returns with these stupid action figures
once you have ten how much benefit do
you really get to
from the 11th so I think it's I'm gonna
put it almost at the not okay end but
not totally because ultimately there's
nothing illegal here in sex sex
education class the students are taught
that since the sexes are equal the girls
should sleep with as many guys as they
want without fear of being considered
[ __ ] no I don't think that's okay
because it's not if they're equal I
don't see guys being told that and it
doesn't seem useful to tell girls that
either I mean it just doesn't it doesn't
follow so I think that that's that's not
okay a man sets up an unlicensed medical
practice but makes all of his customers
sign a contract acknowledging that he is
not a licensed physician I think that
this is absolutely not okay this is one
of those areas where you know
libertarians like to say as long as
people have all of the information then
you don't need a nanny state to tell
them what is and is not okay
no medicine much like insurance much
like pharmaceuticals these are areas
where we can't simply count on people
fully even comprehending what it means
to be an unmet unlicensed medical
practice I think that this is completely
not okay when Kelly asked Stephen out on
a date he sneers and says like I'm in a
date a woman who looks like my
overweight bulldog listen I think that
this is completely disgusting thing I
would never say it but there's nothing I
mean okay so this is uh this is a
relationship to potential relationship
Stephen makes it clear he doesn't like
the appearance of a woman I would never
say this but ultimately is there
anything morally wrong with saying this
the repercussion will be that Stephen
may have a hard time getting a
relationship I'm just gonna leave it in
the middle Tim asks his father for
permission to stay out late because his
classmates are throwing a party when his
father refuses Tim slams the door in his
face it's starting to border on sort of
physical violence it's unnecessary but
and it's not how I would like a child to
behave but there's nothing there's no
big moral wrong that is being done here
I have a hard time feeling super
strongly one way or the other
jack and Willard classmates Will's
father is a lawyer when he picks up will
from school he refuses to say hi to
Jack's father because he's only a
janitor III think that this is a type of
elitism that I don't
like at all it's some people behave this
way and these people exist in the world
and that's it I don't know what else to
say when Lily tells her classmates su
that it's her dream to be prom queen sue
laughs out loud and says you're too ugly
for that okay I mean I don't like it
it's not it's similar to you know it's
it's unnecessarily cruel my approach
would be something like you know a lot
of people want to be prom queen and it's
tough and even if you don't make it it's
not any kind of judgement you know
whatever but it's hard to like feel like
this is the worst possible thing to do
so I'll just go one notch over Dan turns
up the TV just as his father is talking
about his military service I think that
that's okay I mean listen that's the
negotiation parent and child need to
figure out how to have these
conversations
John soccer coach decides that everyone
on the team must wear black soccer shoes
but on the day of the match John turns
up in white soccer shoes instead it's
very hard for me to really feel strongly
about that it's not proactively okay it
seems like it's you know going against
what the coach says I think questioning
Authority is fine it seems like kind of
a pointless opposition to Authority did
he do it on purpose then you do it as an
accident I don't know I just leave it in
the middle okay let me pause briefly
just to thank some people golden Jericho
has subscribed for the second month in a
row at Tier one people are saying that
I'm gonna get an interesting moral
assessment as a result of my reaction
I'm into that let's see what happens let
me say thanks to Grayson Grayson
Forrester Grayson Forrester has signed
up and is the fourth new member of the
evening for up there info over there
phone lines opening if we get to 15 Oh
before I finish up this test the
voicemails are streaming in the phone
lines aren't open yet the phone lines
may open if we get 15 members but they
are not yet open
and I'm just getting flooded with
voicemails let's take a listen to one
other one just to see sort of what's
going on I David I was calling as I
wanted to know about the minimum wage
federal minimum wage going to $15 an
hour I I don't have a problem with that
but I am serious about how it's gonna
affect the cost of goods because I it
it's gonna be an issue I feel but
because I mean people aren't gonna take
a pay decrease at the top yeah okay I've
talked about that already
number of videos on it let's listen to
one other one remember the phone lines
aren't open yet they may open hey David
this is Mark Victor I'm doing a show
called the valley inside MKULTRA okay
I'm not even that seems like it's
somebody inviting me to a program or
promoting something and we're not going
to uh we're not gonna get involved with
out right now okay let me finish up this
test in sex education class the students
are asked to inflate a condom with their
mouth I think it's not okay not because
I have any kind of like moral hang-up or
anything like that it just doesn't seem
particularly productive or relevant to
the education or to understanding how a
condom works
Scott Scott hosting a dinner party for
dessert he serves chocolate cake shaped
to look by like dog poop I think it's
stupid and it's unappetizing but I think
it is marginally okay and then Scott
will have to deal with the repercussions
of doing something like that and Scott
may lose friends when Carl soccer team
is squaring off against the team of
another nation he sings along to the
other teams national anthem instead of
his own what's the principle at play
here right is the principle at play
being a team player meaning that when
you do something like sing along to the
other teams national anthem you're not
being a team play you know I for stuff
like lack of patriotism I just don't
care you know I mean it's it's more like
trolling than anything else I have a
hard time saying I'm against it but it
wouldn't be necessarily the person I
want on the team I guess it's just kind
of stupid and mocking as someone says
but you know it's it's alright Christian
bakery refuses to custom decorate a cake
with chocolate letters that would carry
a pro-gay message
I don't think this is okay and this is a
big political debate I am against this
type of thing I think that if you I mean
listen it's a legal question in some
states you're not allowed to do that in
other places it is legal but more of a
moral issue
I don't like it I'm against this and I
think that particularly is I think
sexual orientation should be a protected
class and therefore refusing service
on the basis of that protected class
would be against the law the principal
of a school says that none of her
students are allowed to draw Mohammed on
the school premises or to bring Mohammed
cartoons to school I think that this is
not okay and any religious explanation
about why would not be one that
resonates with me I don't think it would
be okay for the school principal to say
this Sarah gets drunk in a bar and makes
out with two strangers at once it's fine
who cares when a homeless man asks mat
for spare change Matt keeps on walking
and says don't talk to me loser that's
not how I treat people so I guess based
on my morality I would say it's not okay
although you know this is not illegal
using both a condom in the pill a
brother and sister decide they want to
sleep with each other just wants to see
what it would be like I read about this
question actually when I read Jonathan
Heights book and there were this was
this the subject of a lot a lot a lot of
study and with just very slight
variations on this one
Jonathan Hite received drastically
drastically different answers from
people and you know it's like I don't I
don't think it's okay it's my reaction
and that is I think the reaction a lot
of people have and probably are meant to
have but then you have well using both a
condom and the pill so you prevent a
pregnancy one of the big problems with
this would be you know that you have a
kid and that there are problems as a
result of inbreeding as it is called III
it's it's not something I would do but
using a condom in the pill you know
kind of like the I can see both sides of
it morally I think it's not okay but I'm
gonna leave it in the middle Tom and
Linda have been dating for almost a year
since they've never agreed to be
exclusive
Tom sleeps with other women without
telling Linda I think that this is
basically okay I mean that's a
conversation I think you know sometimes
people argue at some point it's implicit
that it's an exclusive relationship I
think it's just something that should be
talked out in any relationship I think
it is okay
a pair of parents read about the exotic
delicacies of Africa and the Far East in
the coming week they serve dog meat to
their children I would never do this and
I don't eat any animals that are that
that have a certain level of
intelligence and sociability I don't eat
dog I don't eat whale I don't eat
dolphin I don't eat pig I don't eat you
know all this different stuff but these
did this is very arbitrary so I think it
is okay I would never do it dogs are my
friends not food but I don't think
there's anything objectively wrong Brian
doesn't cooperate with law enforcement
whenever he is pulled over he refuses to
answer questions and starts bickering
with the officer about his rights I
think that this is totally fine I am NOT
one of these you know like cop blocker
sovereign citizen whatever dudes but if
you you know if you don't have to answer
questions I understand not answering
them in order to not potentially
incriminating rights is okay you know at
a certain point it becomes not okay if
you I don't know get violent or whatever
I'm not vegan for people asking me about
that the head of a public department
says that none of her employees are
allowed to smoke at all not even in
their free time I don't think you can do
that I love it I mean I hate smoking but
I don't I don't think you can do that
all right that's all 36 questions I will
give everybody a second to catch up and
then I will look at my results Johnny
loves you has subscribed with twitch
Prime Valhalla has subscribed with a
your one sub I really appreciate that
very much oh this is interesting
this is an interesting post Shrek likes
America has an assessment of my morality
I guess
David's moral calculation mr. Pakman is
largely an empathetic person though he
has many sociopathic tendencies wrong
I took the sociopath test a couple
streams ago and I was off the charts
below like I was I was so low on
sociopathic so you're wrong he is
against the lawyer being mean to a
janitor however he's fine with comparing
people to an overweight Bulldog as well
as incest and cheating David should
certainly contemplate his moral beliefs
may God have mercy on his soul I love it
okay what I mind clarifying my
meat-eating preferences it's something
I've been going back and forth okay yeah
so I am NOT vegetarian I try to go with
like a Mediterranean diet I limit meat
consumption so I probably have fish
probably fish twice a week and poultry
once or twice a week and then otherwise
I eat mostly vegetarian food I don't eat
pork I'm not introducing any new meats
to my diet I wouldn't eat dolphin I
don't eat elk I am NOT interested in
trying turtle or any of this stuff I
think for environmental reasons it's
good to limit meat consumption it
doesn't seem to be the healthiest thing
to eat a ton of meat and I have know if
you've read about animal rights you
might know about what's called like the
sliding scale animal rights paradigm
which is that you know once you agree
that the penalty should not be the same
for deliberately killing a gorilla as
deliberately killing an ant like once
you've conceded that then you're talking
about gray area and for me I draw the
line where it is right for me basically
don't do veganism discussions yeah I'm
not I'm not interested in veganism and
it's just not I'm just I'm just that
I've given you what I do Matthew Smith
is a new member on my website thanks
Matthew that is number 5 out of 15 we
are now just 10 new
members away from opening up the phone
lines all right let's get to my results
finish okay moral foundation stuffs your
moral foundations our care
I am closest to a left liberal fairness
I am very low what does that mean
interesting loyalty
I am closest to a left liberal followed
by a libertarian and then a conservative
on authority I am closest to a left
liberal all right on purity I am closest
to a left liberal and on liberty I am
closest to a left liberal that's
interesting so a lot of people were
saying I was going to get results that
were out of whack but it seems that on
basically everything other than fairness
maybe my fairness found moral
foundations are out of whack on
everything other than fairness I
basically aligned with left liberalism
which is not not surprising and for
people saying that the questions lacked
context I completely completely agree
with you a hockey for life 74 thanks for
subscribing for the second month in a
row I really appreciate that
unfair David what's unfair about this I
answered the questions the way I thought
about them and it looks like I'm a left
liberal according to this individual
seeking to uphold individual liberty
while taxing the market yeah it's
basically social democracy some very
very interesting stuff do an IQ test
instead yeah there we go
redeemed highlight my message what does
that mean redeemed highlight my I don't
understand what some of these things
mean hmm interesting
all right I'm getting messages from
people that they have donated and sent
me messages let me see if I can find any
of those but I'm not actually seeing too
many here love your show on this format
I think I read that one
the show yeah I'm actually not seeing
that I'm missing a bunch of donation
messages interestingly enough but okay
Sisyphean zero has subscribed for the
second month in a row at Tier one I
appreciate that thank you very much okay
that was the moral foundations test at
IDR Labs calm okay
so let's see I didn't realize let me
check in with a couple of people I
didn't realize that Hassan was back so
let me just talk to a couple of people
on discord and see if anybody wants to
check in let's see here Hassan is
streaming hey I heard you are back
I'm live want to catch up five minutes
let's see what's up with her son just
for kicks you know yeah this abyss is
YouTube subscribers on the screen it's
not uh oh did I even change it no I
didn't oh wait a second here we go
I don't even know what's going on here
oh there we go let's see what Hassan
says he may be very busy
yeah I know Hasan was banned let's just
see what's happening on his it's
happening on his channel what is this
like global global banks like the
central banks I don't Shahin ich
magnethermic aluminum Cyprus you dingus
the walk thing is what's happening
maybe now he's seeing my message long
silences on as bad as the Western media
says he's pretty bad yeah pac-man is
waiting you're watching your stream on
his stream please change your clothes
for Jamie so you look like less of a bum
I'm not gonna do that okay
he's watching yeah they're worried that
they won't be able to take more islands
from Greece and the rest of Cyprus no I
think they're just most are more so
worried about Northern Cyprus is just
there occupied territory I think that's
like an ongoing threat always is he some
maybe he's not seeing my message who
knows you know a man named Shannon so I
don't speak Turkish unfortunately but
that uh that's not that's not gonna work
let's try destiny instead let's see what
I haven't talked to either of these guys
for a while actually
sent them both an email last week but
type something in his chat okay all
right we'll see if anybody sends me a
message oh it looks like he might be
writing back or no destiny is sure you
want to shop Oh destiny wants to be
wants to do something let's see see
what's up with destiny
go for it all right let's see how can I
call them start boys call
hello hello
hmm
I don't know if he can hear me
this is weird what's going on
he can hear me why can't I hear him
that's the weirdest thing
thank God I'm not a boomer okay I can
hear him oh [ __ ] wait hello hey hey
how's it going hey how are you pretty
good how you do what's new just nothing
I guess just streaming in mimin I got
back from Canada in Texas a week ago
going to London in a tomorrow for a
little bit oh no way back in we're uh
we're in Canada uh Toronto
okay I was close to you kind of I think
isn't Toronto kind of close to New York
Toronto's not far from New York and and
I'm not in New York but it's all oh ya
know you live in somewhere else I don't
know if you said oh no I don't say
probably I gotcha yeah right no no I
mean the Boston area okay yeah yeah okay
yeah it's not listen I'm I'm gonna be
honest dude all that stuff over there
and the east-northeast it's all the same
[ __ ] to me okay but right the next time
did you um how devastated were you by
Hassan being banned for seven days I'm
pretty devastated I guess I mean yeah do
you I like have no idea what the things
are people's people just troll me
because I don't know anything about
twitch so they're like you can't even
mention his son's name during his ban or
you'll get banned and it's like I'm not
so stupid to think that's the case okay
so here's how it which works is when a
streamer is banned on Twitch
you're not allowed to platform that
streamer right right so you can't like
go and watch like a ton of videos of
them or like have them on a disk or call
with you like for them to circumvent
their ban but like I found personally
that like you can usually like talk
about what you can always talk about a
person or like if there's something very
relevant you can watch your whatever but
just the goal is you don't want somebody
like skirting their ban
using and like another person stream
yeah so like last week on my stream I
was watching a clip of Alex Jones
interviewing there's this guy who his
name's Carl Benjamin really but he goes
by Sargon of Akkad you probably never
had multiple real-life debates with him
I hate that guy but yeah yeah I'm
shocked do you even heard of him
actually but in any case I you know cuz
Alex Jones was banned from like
everything so it's like am I allowed to
play now it's Joan clips off and Alex
Jones clip off of [ __ ] shoot I did it
and I guess it was fine yeah yeah I
would challenge twitch greatly if I got
banned for something like that if like
somebody like
Alex Jones banned from twitch if I
couldn't cover like a news event like
that yeah I would take that content to
another platform and I'd be like pretty
vocal about that would be a pretty
stupid thing
so I'm now as you know I've only been
because you're following my twitch
career so closely as I'm sure I'm gonna
hear a lot of all my people watching
what eclipse of you being a boomer and
everything but yeah okay I so I'm now
like I'm now on unlike this the full
second month so I lost obviously like a
huge number of my twitch prime subs so
like what is the strategy for getting
those people to re-subscribe just
mentioning it um well you have to figure
that like for any new venture you do
there's always gonna be a flurry of
excitement when you originally embark on
something right yeah so you have to take
into account that like that thing will
be really exciting there's gonna be a
flurry of excitement around that and
then it'll kind of taper off and then
your goal is like during these big
bursts of excitement is to hold on to as
much without audience as possible by
showing them the content that you think
is the most important that you do or the
most captivating that you do right yeah
sure yeah so I mean like in terms of
like holding on to sobs I mean it's just
a matter of like like how often do you
stream like streaming on a consistent
schedule streaming pretty often like
that kind of stuff is pretty important
yeah III probably need to be streaming
more I mean I'm doing like two to three
streams a week just in the mid you know
with everything else that I'm doing
that's what I've been doing lately and
what is this September thing people are
telling me I should be doing um
apparently I think you get a discount if
you subscribe to your favorites if your
to your favorite twitch streamers you
subscribe you're famous your favorite
[ __ ] twitch streamers right now you get
a 50% discount on all of these
subscriptions guys amazing right right
right so listen I announced today that
I'm gonna be interviewing Sam Harris in
the next week oh ho god that's awesome
is there anything like what do you think
would be he hasn't said any agenda it's
just like a lot of his followers said he
should be on my podcast on my show so he
agreed to do an hour like is there
anything that you think absolutely has
to be talked about with him I would want
to roast him on philosophy but in terms
of like political stuff what has he been
in a hot water recently well there's
this one thing where in the past he said
that like when an Islamic terrorist
tells us that they did it because of the
Quran or whatever for Mohammed whatever
they say that we should take that
seriously like when they say that we
have to believe that they're sincere but
then after
some of these white supremacist
manifestos recently came out he was like
well I don't know that I would take that
seriously like they could be trolling
and it seems like sort of a double
standard to me so I want to explore that
like I think we should just unless we
have a real specific reason to
disbelieve someone stated motives for
committing terror we should probably
just assume that they're genuine sure
yeah you should um yeah that would be an
interesting point to go into for sure
also I don't know if it matters like
imagine if a ton of people started to
murder people and they stayed at some
ideology like even if it was a troll if
people are willing to troll in the name
of that ideology and murder people I
mean like that's probably worth looking
at as well right yeah for sure but I
mean I guess like so okay the example
would be if a whole bunch of people go
out and do mass shootings and say that
they're doing it because they're
opposing single-payer health care but
really there are white nationalists it
would be a crazy red herring to them oh
yeah it's single-payer health care
that's causing these mass shootings and
to treasure everything about it but
that's like that's another level you're
getting into like false flags and stuff
which is yeah highly conspiratorial now
the burden of evidence is quite large
for you to overcome to actually show
that that's what's going on right yeah
yeah for sure
cool all right well good so are you do
you have a plan for next week for the
third democratic debate are you gonna do
anything around that um I'm gonna be I
think I'm gonna be in London I'm nothing
from the fifth to the twelfth one is
that okay well it's gonna be really late
at night it's on the twelfth oh yeah
[ __ ] I don't or shoot wait are you mad a
lot of City off running your stream I
don't know it's twitch I mean I can I
don't know what you how you prefer to do
your comm oh yeah no I love swearing
okay yeah yeah I don't know if um I
don't know if I'll be able to and I'm
also not sure I'm gonna handle it it's a
big gamble honestly like the problem
twitch is getting three DMCA's is like
your channel is probably gone and I
think it lasts forever is what they told
me last I said so like having two would
be really scary because that means I
could get dinged for any random thing
and then I'm completely screwed yeah you
or something or go I'm actually gonna
ask YouTube to see if they can get ABC
to whitelist me and then if they don't
do that then I might just chance it on
twitch I don't know mm-hmm who knows
anyway what are you doing in London um
what am i doing in LA oh I just hang out
with friends
oh all right cool yeah all right man
good well I'll leave you to it what's
this game you're playing here you it's
like a physics simulator so you build
rockets and shoot them into space
fascinating and people watch you play
this stuff yeah believe it or not people
watch me do anything I'm a big streamer
man I know it's that this entire world
is just stunning to me it really is yeah
I'm sure people would ask the same right
you go online and you talking about
politics people watch that right yeah
yeah it is just as weird honestly it's
like who cares what I say no yeah well
that's kind of any way to say but sure
all right Stephen destiny Whannell ii
yeah what's up um if you haven't have
you listened to um have you listened to
Sam Harris his conversation with Ezra
Klein what do you mean from like a year
or two ago yeah I have but I should
review I should refresh on it before the
interview yeah that's a really good
conversation that like super shows that
sam harris has like some pretty big
blind spots when it comes to his own
biases like he tries to say like oh you
know like i just want to be a pursuer of
truth and I'm trying to be objective
blah blah blah and then like Ezra will
ask him like okay well why do you look
at this thing over that thing is it go
well cuz I think it's obviously wrong
it's like okay you don't see how you're
doing the same thing that you're accused
only people doing like it's it's really
really interesting I think Ezra like
holds him pretty well to the fire there
in terms of being honest about like his
beliefs and how objective he's saying
he's being you know alright yeah I'm
definitely gonna review that before the
interview mm-hmm cool all right man good
to check-in I'll let you get back to
doing your thing okay cool thanks Lori
talk to you soon - yep yep all right all
right let's now check in with Hassan and
see what's going on there
back over to Hassan he's doing with her
care staff all right let's check in with
us on here
David hey how are you I don't know if
you hear me
but yeah we can have a can hear you I
see I see your when I see the green
around your your face which means which
indicates oh you can hear me why can't I
hear you this is the same issue you had
last time goddamnit
why does this always happen oh yeah hold
on let's see this is like Inception it
looks like he's reacting destiny talked
to me and I'm watching I Drive stream
device ok can you talk again hello hello
Oh yep we got it was online so what's
going on you're back yeah I'm back well
Oh first and foremost just so you know
half the time the chat is just like
messing with you I mean a lot of like
twitch chat is just it's just like
trying to fool and in trick the streamer
I've been there done that right but it's
also good because like you know you get
clipped out and they post it on LSS and
all these various other subreddits and
then you gain a larger audience and
that's great but also like twitches
Terms of Service is very very serious as
evidenced by a 7-day band that I
received but you mean and what like what
is it that they might trick me into
doing that would be a problem I don't
think they'll trick you into doing
something like that's that would get you
banned unless they send you a clip and
then you click on it but I know you're
you're not gonna do that anyway right I
have links blocked in my chat yeah then
then yeah like it's just mostly it's
just mostly stuff like that um they know
they'll make you like click on a link
that has like a dick in it or something
and then like you know and then mass
like don't go in and mass report it does
it just fun thing it's fun stuff I don't
know if you have a lot of like hater
Watchers at this point so I don't know
if they'll I don't know
they'll do that to you but it's hard to
know John honestly even if they even if
they do that though honestly the only
the best thing that you can do is
immediately stop turn off the vaad like
turn it off completely and delete the
delete the bog and then just start over
yeah and then just restart it yeah it
was like they're very they're twitch is
very understanding in a sense that wait
what is this John John hobby what I
don't know what people would say anyway
um I don't know what people are saying
half the time in my dad either so that's
like don't don't take that into
consideration but how is how is your
experience it's pretty good I mean so I
was just telling Steven destiny bunnell
the second that you know the new month
rolled over so I lost like hundreds and
hundreds of twitch Prime subs and now
it's just like figuring out how all that
works and getting everybody back and all
of that stuff but I'm learning it you
know I don't know yeah yeah yeah you got
room every day right I mean I just can't
do that my lifestyle does not allow for
that yeah you go to like fun places
around the world yeah yeah I told I told
my audience by the way they were like
when are you going on the ROG thing and
I was like you know the day I got to
Aruba
I got a direct message from Hasan saying
do you want to go on tonight and I was
like I have no streaming equipment and
I'm in a rubra yeah but I would still
like to do that I know it's not really
my scene but it seems even if I just go
on and just do my thing and it
completely doesn't fit it's still I
think would be funny oh yeah yeah I mean
reviewing Sam Harris in the next 7 days
anything I want he said my program was
recommended there's no set agenda oh wow
yeah that's really cool
I love that dude I love that you have
the capacity to bring on like IDW guys
and stuff and that they don't regard you
as like a hostile environment well see
no I well even if you I'm not saying
you're like soft on anyone
one of your like early ben shapiro
debates is one of my favorites i think
you talk to about like rpgs and stuff
where is yes and the second amendment
it's very like a lot of people don't get
to do that like that sam harris never
[ __ ] come on money show you know what
i mean like there's just no way because
it's they be like no why would I do that
he is gonna yell at me and and say some
dumb [ __ ] where they're like oh well
this is a serious interlocutor and
that's a good thing I'm gonna try I mean
hopefully I want to just get you know
we've been sort of trying to get him on
for a while so I want to make sure that
I get a bunch of stuff in and and get
everybody's money that's worth so to
speak even though it's a free show but
it's a it's a metaphor yeah no I
understand um do you know what you guys
are gonna talk about a dollar it's it I
mean I want so one thing is he's had
critiques of the left and I've had
critiques of the left but I think
they're different critiques so I want to
talk about like what do we think are
actually the productive things to do
self critiques of and where are we kind
of like devouring ourselves I think he's
on the left and yeah I I mean he's not a
right winger in my mind and I know that
those are people always say just being
for gay marriage doesn't make you a left
winger man I get that I get that but I
mean if you look at the people in that
group the the IDW it's like Eric
Weinstein is on the Left sam Harris is
on the left but in different areas of
the left or enclaves I guess I would say
and doesn't mean we agree with
everything they say yeah what do you
think about is basically charles murray
charles mark always i always forget
I think it's charles murray is the
yellow curve guy I mean I thought that
that was who I thought that entire thing
was completely horrible poor yeah and
then there was I'm sure you've seen his
like recent fatigues and stuff in
regards to the way he defends or not
defends rather but like the way he
covered and you're gonna do your own due
diligence Nero
investigation into this I know I'm just
like saying like I don't know if you've
seen this or not I'm just trying to like
point you in in a different direction if
you're interested yeah um he was talking
about the manifestos of the white
supremacist shooters just mentioned this
to Stephen destiny bonel ii yeah yeah
and and he said something along the
lines of like I mean he basically
defended them by saying like oh that's
multifaceted and like they're mostly
trolling they're not actually you know
these guys aren't actually serious like
there isn't like some sort of
ideological underpinning to the violence
that they commit you know what I mean
yeah ya know and he said the opposite
but you know back when it's Islamic
terror listen we gotta just these are
genuine people I'm in asking about and
the things I know he's already been
asked about it and I've already seen
some of his reactions to it but I still
want to talk about it yeah it's just so
it's just so strange to me that that you
know those two ideas can exist in the
same mind where you can be like no like
every every Islamic terrorist like there
is no geopolitical reason as to why
they're radicalized or anything like
that it's not a consequence of like u.s.
foreign policy whatsoever
it totally is like it totally exists in
this ideological vacuum where like Islam
is just like really dangerous uniquely
versus white supremacy is just the mean
yeah I mean my view is basically all of
these things are multifaceted and give
unless we have some particular reason to
question the motives that are stated by
the perpetrators those that need to be
taken seriously period I mean I don't
know what else to else to really even
say it but yeah I'm definitely gonna
talk to him about that oh [ __ ] yes I
know of her listen there's I'll let you
go so you can do that but one thing I
wanted to ask you about was I posted a
video shooting hoops the other day was
the person filming our mutual friend
that went to dinner with us when last
time I was in LA no oh I thought I
recognized the voice wait which mutual
friend
no come on oh oh no no oh no no no not
at all no okay don't think I don't think
our mutual friend plays basketball like
that yeah cool all right man I'll let
you go do your thing but good to
check-in glad you're back and I'll send
you a message about debate coverage next
week I was gonna ask you some stuff cool
all right man talk to you soon sorry
bike all right there is Hassan [ __ ]
yeah very good
okay let me see there's a whole bunch of
people that I have to thank now that
I've missed let me see where I left off
before cuz I don't want to miss it miss
anybody who is supporting the work that
I do
ZT any press subscribed for the second
month asking do i watch Patriot Act with
Hasan Minhaj I've never seen it McLovin
1189 welcome thank you for your second
month in a row snake master triple 7
subscribed for the second month in a row
Roddy grotty subscribed with twitch
prime rawhide kids subscribed at tier
one Nash tak subscribed at Tier one the
Silver Nico cheered 140 bits jh8 CS
subscribed for two months with prime
saying you do great work David thank you
thank you
daki a man subscribed with prime links
milkshake subscribed tier one hello I'm
Han subscribed with prime Thank You
Frick he'll new twitch prime subscriber
Ren VAX keep on keeping on pakman
subscribed for two months with twitch
prime l3 dickson subscribed for two
months appreciate that the mushroom man
and malazan 426 the newest twitch prime
subscribers thank you so much really
appreciate the support okay there were a
couple of things david patten twitch
persona his in real life persona or a
broadcast persona man i don't know what
you're talking about
okay so all right the less so it looks
like we're not gonna take phone calls I
think I am probably set up I kind of
joked about this last time and I am
actually set up to do it I could play a
little Mario just because it's like the
only video game I really play let me see
if I can get set up properly for this I
need to plug in my television to my
capture card and all of that stuff right
as people know I discussed last time
it's a really really important thing to
do let's see here I've got to figure out
exactly how to do this just bear with me
for a moment this could be a disaster
but it could be really funny let me see
here okay I've got to set this up the
right way though this is actually gonna
be pretty tough
oh no that is not good something insane
just happened here oh god everything's
going wrong folks everything is going
completely wrong Wow
yeah so that did not work let me see how
else I can do this hmm
this is SNES Super Mario World
try this once more oh oh I think I got
it now that's not gonna work that's not
gonna work let me see I've got to figure
out ah there we go all right this one
I'll try this once more this may or may
not work what's my favorite fishing rod
you know I don't really have one I must
say okay
can anybody hear that or is that just me
oh man
something is definitely happening but
man so so okay so I own the game so it's
okay to play it on an emulator right can
someone tell me otherwise if we don't
play this if we don't go goal and it's a
real problem okay all right
let's give it a shot okay here we go
we'll start a new game and let's see if
I ever I haven't played this in so long
it really brings back memories come on
[Music]
yeah yeah I own this game I've owned
this game forever all right here we go
let's see if I remember all the all the
tricks you know I forgot you got a duck
all right I'm gonna be good I'm gonna
crush this in a second here we go
[Music]
the background I don't even know what
people are talking about here we go
the background is clipped nothing's
clipped I don't know what people are
talking about I think we're gonna do
this yeah I really remember all these
levels from being a kid it's crazy
yeah roasting Millennials 4head that's
fine remember this I think there's a yep
there we go Wow just comes back to you
it's crazy
Oh missed that all right so like I
played this yesterday it's really crazy
it's shocking anyone still here if I
haven't lost half my viewership by the
time I'm done it'll be really shocking
all right let's keep it going yellow
switch palace this is just the best all
right people don't know this game this
is the so that you need for a Nintendo
you had Super Mario one two and three
and then this was the first one for
Super Nintendo Super Mario World this to
me is the best game by far I played all
of them and I think this is nothing
nothing's as good as this yeah this
Mario game has the best mechanics
absolutely
absolutely and totally alright so so far
no secret exits let's see if I actually
remember some of the secret exits
because they are there are a lot of them
I've not played Odyssey Super Mario 3
first NES is a good one though
[Music]
is Yoshi here alright no secret exit yet
though I think it's still a couple
levels away
[Music]
there's a vine here yeah definitely want
to keep Yoshi yeah alright and off we go
yeah these early levels are so easy hmm
really bringing back memories I must say
this game just puts you in a good mood
doesn't it all right still no suit does
anyone remember where the first secret
exit is I think it's still a bit later
it's hard to plan answer questions at
the same time I will admit that is not
an area of expertise did I know Prime
subs are half-off this month I didn't
know that Oh
people are saying change the category to
Mario all right let me try it
category Mario Mario Paint Mario does it
need to be Super Mario World
Super Mario Brothers Tetris Nintendo you
know I don't see the exact one Super
Mario World there it is update info
alright let's see if that does anything
yeah of course I'm playing a console
right now yeah that's exactly right
alright let's keep going
off we go it's like I don't need every
coin come on oh now there we go got to
get those extra lives yeah I know I
understand that but there's there's so
many extra lives available like if
you're not up to fifty extra lives in
this game pretty quickly you're doing
something very wrong I don't really get
those single coins in those Starr
buttons that really make sense there we
go all right now we're moving along
people wondering well you need every
coin for a speedrun is that right so a
speedrun you need you're supposed to get
every single available coin that seems
crazy no David you don't know okay all
right good thanks for letting me count
all right yes I remember this level this
is a doozy and off we go all right there
we go I hate losing Yoshi it's like the
worst thing got him all right very good
we're really moving along now man this
is just the best game are you I don't
play any new video games are they as
good as this I don't it's just hard to
imagine that this is a good that
anything good I would do this first
fortress castle all right here we go
sometimes you have to sacrifice the
ocean there's no can't get that anywhere
oh there we go that forgot about that
one I think I can make it we're just
gonna go all right
[Music]
yeah I know I know about I know how to
get the free lives on the fence but who
cares we're like three levels in and I
got fifty all right yep this is my five
thousand dollar gaming PC this is what I
play on it oh not this one
I usually just wait over here until it
slants the other direction yeah there we
go
that's an easy one how many subs for a
house tour we're nowhere close to that
we're very far from that number all
right now I think is when there I'll
play a couple more levels then we're
going to be done yeah yeah my fan of
platformers is that this can they make
the screen bigger the thing about making
the screen bigger is let me see video
like okay I can make it somewhat bigger
let's see here I still want it windowed
scaled to fit screen D s alright let's
try this oh geez I just that is horrible
that's not what we want let's try this
one huh
alright let's try it yeah I know trihex
I almost met him i raided him last time
all right
I think now we get into secret exits
let's take a look then we're gonna be
done
I want the hold on Hammond I wanted the
Cape oops
now we're really moving here yep oh but
the Cape there's the trick where you can
get all of these I remember that tricky
just sloppy ship them about the Cape
call trihex later yeah I don't know
we'll see oh no I don't even want to
deal with these dudes so that's the
secret exit there I'll have to come back
for that
oh no oh god everything going wrong but
we made it out you almost never see the
Cape trick which trick is that what's
the Cape trick all right I'm going right
back in for the secret exit all right
now we can get the Cape all right should
be able to just fly through now and get
the get the secret exit here we go
oh let's see here
Oh No lost it can't do it without the
Cape let's see if I can find one
somewhere all right we should be good
now I guess I'll get Yoshi but where was
that secret oh I think it's coming up
yeah that's the right way to do it can I
fly up there I don't remember now Oh No
there it is remember the way to do this
don't actually remember maybe I just
come back after green switch palace oh
wait maybe I can do it with Yoshi there
it is got it yep jump off Yoshi you were
right all right let's just save this
game I think that's gonna be enough for
today all right very good okay so I
indulged people who were curious it is
amazing how that just comes right back
to you I mean it's really really
stunning I haven't played that and I
don't know how long and you just like
remember every every level that's crazy
I don't know what pagas is or POG I have
no clue what that is but it seems people
like it okay let me say thanks to a
couple of other people before we raid
someone forgot user name three times has
subscribed for a month Borle subscribed
with prime cerulean portal that used to
be my favorite crayon cerulean
subscribed for two months um depite
subscribed with twitch prime know with a
Tier one sub Cylon rights taco flambe
and coder Tim all subscribed with twitch
prime and Steve 420 noscope cheered 10
[ __ ] 10
ten [ __ ] ten bits which I really
appreciate
okay who should we raid last time I
rated trihex nobody has rated me so far
we've rated uh I think we've rated the
serfs before we've rated destiny who
else I don't know who else to raid here
hmm I don't really follow that many
people that's the problem raid has son
my friend pokey main isn't streaming
otherwise we could raid her trihex isn't
even streaming I don't believe so I
don't think I can even really raid him
uh all right let's raid let's raid his
son here we go here we go I'll be back
tomorrow streaming at 6:30 p.m. Eastern
tomorrow all right hope you'll join me
then let's raid Hasan here we go